what up space fam golson here from anime
opera and today it's finally time to
talk about the extremely
popular time loop theory for attack on
titan using all the up-to-date info we
have from all of the new chapters which
suggests that
aaron finally succeeded in breaking the
time loop
i hope you find this topic as
interesting as i did myself
i gotta say i'm pretty into it being a
big fan of time travel esque stories
myself if you do
enjoy seeing these attack on titan
videos and want to keep them coming then
the best thing you could do is warhammer
smash that like button until it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell or you will
miss
future attack on titan videos that's
just the way it works
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
attack on titan playlist where i got
videos on all the titan shifters
all the ackermans and much more link to
that is in the description
and if you're burning up for me to cover
another attack on titan topic
leave your suggestions in the comments
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers
and all i know people sometimes complain
when i use wikipedia as a source but i
purposely got out of the academic world
in part so i can bypass a lot of its
restrictions like
not being able to use wikipedia as a
source when it makes sense to so yeah
i'm unapologetically
now going to quote from wikipedia and
savor every minute of it first we must
define our term
a time loop according to wikipedia and i
quote
is a plot device in fiction whereby
characters re-experience a span of time
which is repeated sometimes more than
once
with some hope of breaking out of the
cycle of repetition
time loops are constantly resetting when
a certain condition is met such as the
death
of a character or a clock reaches a
certain time
the loop starts again possibly with one
or more characters retaining the
memories from the previous loop
end quote now if you haven't heard of
this theory that's been floating around
since as long as i can remember we're
going to go through my own summary and
version of it the short version
is that there's a time loop that will
repeat again and again until a
air and freeze the world and in
particular the aldean people of titans b
emir fritz is freed from her eternity of
slaving away in the unknown lands
and c the shiny centipede creature that
attached to emir
and started all this titan stuff is
killed all of those points are actually
related aaron our protagonist is
arguably a key to breaking this loop as
was further symbolized
by the basement key being around his
neck all the time earlier on in the
series
it is possible that when he dies without
fulfilling the goal of freeing the world
from titans and amir from slavery
then time is turned back perhaps all the
way to when emir inherited the titan
powers or perhaps just to when aaron
wakes up in chapter one
more on that later it is noteworthy on
the wikipedia page that there is a whole
section
about time loops in japanese pop culture
time loops are considered a familiar
trope
in japanese pop culture media especially
in
get this anime so it would not be at all
surprising if isayama
also incorporated this trope into his
own story one of the first times i was
exposed to this trope was when i was
watching
the anime the melancholy of haruhi
suzumiya still one of my favorite anime
to this day the haruhi suzumiya time
loop resulted in the infamous endless 8
aka 8 episodes where the same events
repeated with slight variations until
finally during the last episode
kyon our protagonist broke the loop by
inviting the whole team to come over to
his house the next day
so they could all finish their homework
from summer vacation now you finally get
how important it is to finish your
homework
in that case that was the key to
breaking the loop something that didn't
happen during the last
15 000 plus versions of that summer
vacation
that's right the same events took place
over 15 000
times and one character yuki the alien
aka humanoid
interface actually experienced all of
those versions while being fully
conscious of the repetitions it's been
called the most hated arc in anime
history and you can bet most people
didn't enjoy waiting a whole week
to watch the next episode that was
practically the exact same as the
previous week's episode and doing so
over and over again however as a total
nerd i actually love the concept because
it gives you the tiniest sense
of what it must have been like for yuki
to relive this summer break again and
again
while we had to watch eight 20-minute
episodes before escaping the loop she
had to experience the same summer break
over 15 000 times so it's not that bad
for us when you look at it like that
however from what i gathered the anime
was different from the source material
and originally we were only shown the
final loop in the light novel before it
was broken
that's what i suspect is the case for
attack on titan 2. we are experiencing
the final loop
as our main story and there have been
many loops in the past where aaron did
not succeed in freeing emir fritz
so now let's focus in more on attack on
titan itself in chapter 138 the latest
chapter of attack on titan and the
second last one
ever we saw what appeared to be a
what-if fantasy where aaron
chose to spend the rest of his life with
mikasa in a cabin
because of amir's curse they didn't have
a whole lifetime together but they still
got to spend what remained of aaron's
life in peace
when aaron's time is up due to amir's
curse a short-haired mikasa in the cabin
world says
see you later to aaron as his eyes are
still a bit open
with this in mind let's scroll back to
the first chapter of attack on titan
which by the way was called
to you 2 000 years from now another
reference to time travel
and this is probably amir talking to
aaron since the time between her and him
is roughly 2 000 years although if we're
being super specific with the facts
we've been given
it's less than 1900 but i assume she'd
be rounding up
and what do we see in this first time
travel referencing chapter
we see a short-haired mikasa say see you
later aaron before he opens his eyes
only to ask mikasa when her hair got so
long
to me this sort of seems like aaron
potentially resetting after that last
loop which ended beside the cabin with
mikasa where they despite the happy-ish
ending
once again failed to free amir fritz and
by extension failed to free the future
aldians from the curse of the titans
we even visually see the number 845
as if letting us know that time is
important and that we've returned to
this checkpoint
now to be fair this doesn't have to be
the restart point it could just so
happen that aaron saw the previous loop
aaron's memories
before he woke up notably he tells
mikasa
i feel like i just had the longest dream
and he'll say the exact same thing later
too
after he accesses grisha's memories of
dyna becoming the smiling titan during
chapter 87 he says and i quote
i feel like i just woke up from the
longest dream but this time he realizes
it is not a dream but a memory
interestingly enough the latest chapter
chapter 138
is called a long dream too and this time
mikasa is the one who says she feels
like she just had a long dream from the
cabin world
suggesting that this version of her saw
past memories just like when aaron saw
grisha's
except in her case she probably saw
memories from past
loops and that's why this mikasa didn't
say goodbye to aaron but i'll see you
later
she was aware that the time loop would
reset and they'd see
each other again even if the aaron of
this specific loop
just died from amir's curse and although
aaron doesn't remember exactly what he
saw in chapter 1
except that mikasa's hair was shorter
than it is now he cries suggesting that
his body are somewhere in his
subconscious he's aware of what happened
in the previous loop
and the knowledge of it is bringing him
to tears now another time we saw aaron
randomly cry like this was you guessed
it
after he woke up in a jail cell after
experiencing grisha's memories of dinah
becoming the smiling titan during
chapter 87
and mikasa cried too in the cabin world
after awaking from her
quote-unquote long dream further
suggesting that chapter one aaron was
crying here in the first chapter
because he did in fact just access past
memories
past memories that were probably sent to
him by emir fritz
using the paths that connect her the
coordinate to every other ldn including
aaron at this point
even if he doesn't yet possess the
attack or founding titan powers
notably chapter 122 will be called from
you
2 000 years ago and the chapter is about
emir fritz and her story suggesting that
that 2000 number
is in fact referring to the temporal
bridge between
amir fritz and aaron yeager that chapter
is a very significant one because it
shows exactly when the shiny centipede
creature attached to a mirror and this
whole titan history started
it also contains aaron's reply to emir
in the unknown land aka the land of the
paths that transcends space and time
where emir actually molds all the time
transformations we see
in the real world from the special earth
beneath her feet
even all the gigantic colossal titans
that are released
during the rumbling aaron tells her that
she's not a slave
and that he'll put an end to this world
if she gives him her strength
he tells her she gets to decide whether
to stay here for eternity
or to end it all if we believe in this
time loop theory
what he's really saying is lend me your
power if you want me to set you free
from this eternity of servitude by
finally breaking the time loop as erin
reveals
she must have been waiting 2 000 years
for someone to free her in this way but
that's sort of an understatement because
that doesn't factor in the way time
works in this land of the paths
where an instant titan transformation in
the real world requires painstaking
molding
that lasts for what must seem like an
eternity for amir in this world and it
also doesn't take into account how
emir would have relived those 2 thousand
years many many times
if the time loop theory is correct keep
in mind zeke says
that the relatively short time he spent
there when compared to how much time
emir must have spent there still felt
long
and also dragged out for him so clearly
emir is the yuki
of attack on titan as she's been
conscious and aware during this eternity
of dragged out time and constant
repetitions
thus what was happening during the first
chapter was most likely amir reaching
out to aaron for help
and setting into motion the events that
would eventually lead future aaron to
meet her
in the land of the paths where he could
carry out the plan to end it all
and finally free her from the eternal
time loop when you start
looking at the series through the lens
of this theory
there are many moments that you'll start
to look at in a different way
for instance during chapter 121 future
aaron tells past grisha
to advance even if you die even after
you die
end quote that even after you die
statement
makes more sense if aaron's referring to
future versions of him advancing
in future time loops even if you don't
break the cycle
in this loop keep trying to do so in the
next
and repeat the process no matter how
long it takes
during chapter 89 aaron krueger is
talking to grisha
and there's reason to believe that it's
aaron jaeger talking through krueger at
the same time
as well since he goes on to mention
mikasa and arm and aaron's friends
who haven't even been born yet at this
point kruger tells grisha before passing
on the attack titan power and i quote
love someone inside the walls if you
can't
we're doomed to repeat it all again the
same history the same mistakes
again and again if you want to save them
all mikasa armin
and the others carry out your mission to
the end
end quote this conversation between
krueger and grisha could also be a way
for future aaron to give a message to
the past aaron who is currently
witnessing grisha's memories
in this way aaron is telling himself to
carry out his mission to the end
to not stop until he breaks the loop and
although you could say that when kruger
says doomed to repeat it all again
he just means that future generations
will keep the cycle of hatred going when
you take everything else into account
it's hard not to believe that he's
talking about repeating it all again
because of the time loop you can find
more and more instances like this
littered throughout the story that can
easily be read as having something to do
with the time loop or referring to the
time loop
during chapter 6 before mikisa saves
aaron from a kidnapper she mentions that
she remembers and i quote
seeing this scene before again and again
end quote
as with the kruger moment you can
explain it away by saying that she was
just referring to the world being a
cruel place
and how the strong feet on the weak
she's seen those laws in nature at work
before
and i do think she meant that however at
the same time i also think that this
could be pointing to the fact that they
are
in a time loop repeating things over and
over again consciously mikasa would not
recall past
lives at this point except maybe through
a deja vu experience
but i do think ackerman's have a higher
chance of getting access to memories
of past loops than the other ldns
because their memories are more
difficult to manipulate
than that of the others in fact so far
it's been suggested that their memories
can't actually be rewritten like that of
the other aldeans
using the founding titan power you may
have noticed that the ackermans get
headaches a lot
it is possible that they get headaches
because memories of past
time loops are coming to them while
their mind resists them
notably mikasa's latest headache leads
to her vision of the cabin house which
we're saying for the sake of this video
is what happened in the previous time
loop once she says
she can't take this anymore as if she
can't hold the memory at bay anymore
she gets this vision and she no longer
has a headache
we know that aaron or amir shouldn't be
able to feed
any false memories to an ackerman so
this it would seem
must be a real memory a real memory of a
past life
let's keep going with how other things
can be viewed differently through the
lens of this theory the attack titan's
ability to see future memories might
actually be the ability to see the
memories of
past time loops thus a future memory
could just be a memory of a past
loop that was further along than the
present loop the attack
titan that is always moving forward and
seeking freedom from the loop
might be the only titan power that when
combined with the founding titan power
can gain
full access to the memories of all past
loops
in turn this would explain why aaron is
acting the way he is now
and why he's doing such horrible things
because he may be aware that he tried
every other alternative in every past
loop and it failed to break the cycle
so now this is the only alternative left
he had to be mean
and distant to mikasa and armin where
things may never have worked out the way
they did
so this brings us back to the latest
chapter chapter 138 where aaron seems to
have finally broken the time loop by
having mikasa kill him
the current founding titan while the
shiny centipede creature was outside of
its host's body
in the last panel we saw emir fritz in
the back smiling
suggesting that aaron completed the goal
he promised he would
if she lent him her power he put an end
to it to the loop once and for all
now the shiny centipede creature's cord
to the aldians has been cut
and in the next chapter aldians should
end up being freed from the curse of the
titans in other words
they'll be like everyone else they won't
be able to turn into titans anymore
they won't be affected by amir's curse
the world of paths will cease to exist
and emir and aaron will finally be able
to rest in peace
if you don't know islam has already
revealed what the final panel of the
manga will be
it will be a baby probably historia's
baby being held by an
adult and they will tell the baby and i
quote you are
free my interpretation of this is that
the baby will be free of the titan curse
thanks to aaron
not only has the rest of the world seen
aldians risking their lives to stop
aaron the devil
if aldians will also cease to be able to
become titans once and for all
as i expect then the surviving
inhabitants of the world
will really have no reason to treat the
remaining aliens like monsters and
discriminate against them
thus this aldean baby will also be free
of the world's fear and hatred that all
past aldians were
subject to armin and the others will
stop being able to turn into titans and
they will also be free from emir's curse
just as kruger told grisha aaron will
have carried out his mission to the end
and in that way he will have saved
mikasa and armin
and the aldian nation as a whole just as
he wanted to do
all along and that my friends will be
the end of attack on titan one of the
greatest stories
ever told now before i wrap up i just
want to address some other facets of the
theory
one of the main questions is how is a
time loop possible
well just as in haruhi suzumiya it's
possible that a godlike character is
responsible while the haruki suzumiya
time loop was caused by haruhi who has
the godlike abilities to change destroy
and reshape reality in that series
it is possible the attack on titan time
loop was caused by amir fritz who
similarly has
the godlike abilities to change destroy
and reshape reality in her own series if
amir who once possessed all nine titan
powers
can transcend time and space as we've
seen it's not that far fetched to assume
that she could create a time loop that
would repeat
until someone like aaron helped her
achieve her desired outcome of freedom
while researching the endless 8 i also
came across
something which i thought was
interesting some fans suggested that
they made
the endless 8 arc last 8 episodes
because
8 the number looks like the sign
infinity infinity in turn points to the
idea of being in an infinite time loop
the concluding episode of the endless 8
arc where the infinity loop was broken
was the 19th episode broadcast for
season 2
or the 9th new episode either way the
interesting thing is that the number
nine physically looks like the number
eight or the infinity sign would look
if the loop was broken so it's very
fitting that the endless eight loop was
broken on the ninth episode i am fully
aware
that i may be looking too much into this
but i like to look at numbers especially
when we're talking about time travel
in attack on time's case it seems random
to finish on the 139th
chapter however since that will be the
first chapter where the characters have
actually escaped the time loop and are
finally free from it
it seems very fitting for it to end with
a 9
just like with haruhi suzumiya and the
number 13 in front of the 9
is not insignificant either as we know
13 represents emir's curse in attack on
titan and by extension
the titan curse more generally while the
numbers 13
8 suggests that we are trapped in a
cursed and endless titan time loop
13 9 suggests that we finally escaped
the cursed
titan time loop and emir's curse again
this last part
may be looking into it way too much and
i fully acknowledge that but i thought
it was interesting nonetheless and so i
wanted to share it in light of
everything else we know
about the time loop trope and the attack
on titan series
anyways that is it for this video thank
you so much for watching
let me know whether you think the time
loop theory will pan out for attack on
titan or not
either way i hope you enjoyed the video
no matter what happens i personally
enjoy this theory
so much that i will consider it an
alternate ending if isayama doesn't
actually end up using it
if you did enjoy this video and want to
keep the attack on titan videos coming
then the best thing you could do
is warhammer smash that like button
until it's blue
imagine this what if we're in a time
loop right now
and the only way out is for you to
finally smash that like button
our collective fate is in your hands if
you haven't be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell and
select all or you will miss future
attack on titan videos
and while you wait for the next one to
drop feel free to check out our growing
attack on time playlist where i got
videos about all the time shifters all
the acronyms and much more
link to that is in the description also
feel free to leave suggestions for
future attack on time videos
that you are burning up to see in the
comments and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you